los sepultureros y trabajadores
funerarios argentinos amenazan con dejar
de trabajar
justo cuando argentina atraviesa su peor
momento desde el inicio de la pandemia
exigen prioridad en la campaña de
vacunación tras un año de trabajo sin
tregua y cuya intensidad ha aumentado en
las últimas semanas muchas cosas que
puedes contagiarte en este lugar por
encima que tenemos el club y que esto es
niza nubles también no es es una es una
guerra que uno tiene diariamente en este
lugar no el miedo está no por eso
queremos que llegue la vacuna para todos
de cumplirse la amenaza se cesaría la
actividad de trabajadores de cementerios
y crematorios y funerarias no sólo
resaltan el riesgo al contacto sino el
desgaste emocional tras más de un año
sin un respiro lamentablemente ahora que
nosotros tenemos que recibir los cuerpos
bongo y los tenemos que hacer
lamentablemente con mucho cuidado pero
lo tenemos que hacer y lo hacemos con
todo el dolor porque
y te da mucho dolor de la gente cuando
no puede ingresar en vez de ingresar
toda su familia y analizar una parte es
muy muy triste muy complicado argentina
registró el martes su máximo récord de
muertes desde el inicio de la pandemia
con 745 fallecidos el jueves el
presidente anunció un nuevo
confinamiento estricto de 9 días a
partir de este 22 de mayo en la mayor
parte del país la advertencia de huelga
ocurre mientras la campaña de vacunación
en el país avanza a un ritmo mucho más
lento a lo prometido por el gobierno un
18 por ciento de los ciudadanos han
recibido al menos una dosis y sólo un
4,5 por ciento ha recibido la segunda
inyección en un país de casi 45 millones
de personas